Protest around statues
have been one of many polarizing moments,
for Americans, and for
the rest of the world.
And I promise we'll get to that.
But first, let's talk about breakups.
For a lot of people out there
who've spent a significant
amount of time with someone
only to have it end badly,
a common cathartic process,
is removing any imagery
that reminds you of them.
Whether it's a gift they
gave you, or a trinket,
or actual photographs, and
today, it's never been easier.
Companies like Adobe and Apple
make it part of their
advertising campaigns.
We all engage in some level
of editing our own history.
We remember the good parts,
maybe forget the bad parts,
but when this happens on a societal scale,
things become much more complicated.
Especially when some people feel as if
they're the ones being erased.
And when it comes to, say destroying art,
well, we've been doing that
since the beginning of recorded history.
As long as we've been making art,
we've been destroying it.
That's Professor Erin Thompson
of John Jay College of Criminal Justice.
And I'm an expert in the
deliberate destruction of art,
and art crime in general.
As long as someone has thought someone
is great enough to make a statue of,
someone else has come along and thought,
nope, we're tearing that down,
that person isn't great at all.
I think of the Egyptians sculpting statues
of themselves to last for
eternity, to put in their tombs.
For many Egyptians,
eternity didn't last forever.
Especially when it came to their noses.
The most common question
that Egyptologists are asked,
why are the noses broken
on ancient Egyptian art?
Research done by this man,
Edward Bleiberg, shows that
this damage wasn't done
by the long march of time.
Rather, it was a very specific
practice, called iconoclasm.
This is the act of
attacking established values
and institutions, through
destroying symbols.
Attacking a statue is somewhere
deep in the human brain.
Something like attacking
that person themselves.
In Egyptian mythology,
statues were thought of
as spiritual vessels.
So removing a nose,
was a way to disable that
connection to the afterlife,
but Bleiberg also theorizes
about another culprit
for this destruction,
early Christian monks.
Every new society when it's creating,
destroys images of the past.
We see same thing happening
in the French revolution,
with the overthrow of the
aristocratic government of France,
there is also an overthrow of statues.
This is a cyclical process,
and it's happened countless
times throughout history.
Once the society rises,
it builds statues to represent itself.
And then as a new society comes along,
it removes or destroys those old statues,
and replaces them, with their own.
An example of that cycle
on a shorter timeline,
are the Christopher Columbus statues
across the United States.
Statues of Columbus are fascinating to me
because they were put up,
at a time when Italians
were not necessarily
considered white.
When whiteness was something
that was Northern European.
Statues of Columbus were funded
by Italian-American groups
as a part of an argument that
we are, Italian American.
Don't, reject us, don't
discriminate against us.
Now, statues of Columbus
are being protested by native Americans
who see Columbus as a symbol,
of the fact that they are excluded
from belonging to America.
And while the facts
around Columbus as a man
remain problematic,
as a symbol,
he simultaneously stands
for mass genocide to some,
and national pride to others.
What these, heritage sites and places,
statues and historic buildings do,
is they give us a tangible
sense of the intangible.
This is Professor Laurajane Smith.
She's spent her career
researching, studying
and writing about heritage
and its effects on society,
including a decade long study
in how we interact with heritage sites.
Most people go to reinforce
what they already know,
feel and believe.
And this is one of the issues,
with the heritage debate,
is that, we have this sort of sense that,
heritage, particularly national heritage
has to make us feel good, and
feel good about ourselves.
And when we visit these sites
to reinforce our deeply held beliefs,
it can blind us to realities,
right under our noses.
Smith pointed to a series of interviews
she conducted at Andrew
Jackson's Hermitage in Tennessee,
where visitors had to
walk through an exhibit
on the former president's role in slavery,
before they could enter his
palatial plantation house.
Visitors, engage in an array of responses
that attempted to,
shield themselves from the,
from the negative emotions that,
cut into their sense
of comfort for visiting
this presidential house.
Some people would say, when I asked them,
what did you think of the exhibition?
Would say,
what exhibition? I didn't
notice any exhibition.
So intent where they to get to,
the comforting presidential performance.
Others would go, oh yes
I saw it, but I'm not in,
you know, it's not relevant.
It's not relevant to this,
to this history, I've
come to see, Jackson.
While it may be natural for many of us
to avoid engaging with
the more complicated parts
of our history.
These public forms of art,
are having an impact on us as a society.
Neuroscientists talk
about the halo effect.
And I like to talk about
the pedestal effect.
When we see someone up on a pedestal,
all these assumptions kick in that,
they must be someone who's
there to be respected,
to be praised, to be honored.
So statues are very bad
at communicating nuance
and shades of gray.
They are, what Michael
Bilig has referred to
as a form of banal nationalism,
they are so ubiquitous,
that we tend to, forget
that they're there,
but nonetheless,
are constantly referencing
and, representing particular ideas and,
group identity and so on.
Identity is complicated.
It's much easier to think of America
as a set of almost like
flashes of images of, the flag
and the Statue of Liberty,
a portrait of Washington.
And that is, a shorthand for what it means
to be an American.
So if you change those images,
that changes identity.
Images summarize complex things
and if we want to change complex things
sometimes we need to change
those summary images.
When we're not fighting actual wars,
we often fight wars by using images,
by attacking the idea of
what the other side is standing for.
To say, I don't want a white
supremacist America anymore,
you attack statues
that represents a white
supremacist America.
But watching these images
change in real time,
is much different than walking through
an ancient iconoclasm exhibit in a museum.
While removing or reclaiming a statue,
can give some that same cathartic sense
as removing an ex from a photo,
for others, it feels
like a personal attack.
Not only on their past, but their future.
If you don't,
pay attention to history,
it repeats itself.
Through history people have been horrified
by the destruction of statues because,
that's a sign of our fragility,
that not only our bodies,
but our whole legacy,
any memory of us could be
overthrown, disrespected,
disregarded.
So to defend a statue of really anybody,
is to defend this idea that you yourself
might be around for the future.
Heritage and history
are constant processes
of, reassessing who we
are and who we want to be.
The debate will always be ongoing.
And that,
that in itself is I
think a far more healthy
and constructive,
way of approaching both
heritage and history.